Thought I'd take a moment real quick to explain how ad
networks work. This isn't strictly relative or relevant to this class
but it's kind of a neat example of how cookies are
used. So say you have your browser and it makes a
request to some website and you know, this website responds with
some HTML. You know, one of the things in this in
this HTML could actually be a little one pixel hidden image.
That you don't even see. That makes requests to somebody else.
For example, Google.com. And this in fact happens. And,
because Google.com has an analytic's package set a lot of
websites use to track you know, traffic and what
users are doing. And that sort of thing. And google.com
may, re, respond you know, it'll respond with the
actual pixel image. You know, this might be a, you
know, image source equals you know, Google something. And this
may have a cookie down there that will you know,
assign you some ID, so that when you come back to
the website again and we, you request this pixel again, Google can
track that you are the same user coming back. And you
know, that you know, that's how they know whether you're a new
user or a returning user. And, and so this is you
know, this is an example of, of a third party cookie. You
know, we went to udacity.com in our browser. But we received a
cookie for google.com. You know, Udacity
doesn't receive those cookies, but Google
will, and, and that's how they run their analytics. And, and there
are legitimate uses for this. You know, analytics is a really good example.
We, you know, we use Google Analytics on. You know, we use it
on Reddit and we use it currently on Hipmunk, and udacity uses Google
Analytics as well so we can see, you know, what our traffic
is, what people are clicking on that sort of thing. There's also more
sinister uses, which is actually [LAUGH] Google is a big pro user of
this. Now Google knows something about you. You know, they know that you've
been to this website. And you may go to another website. You know, let's say
it's, it's pets.com and pets.com, you know, returns
HTML, you know, as usual, and it has
the same pixel which goes to google.com. All
of a sudden Google knows hey, you've been
to udacity.com and pets.com because they're like a
common third party here. And Google actually has,
you know, between Google Analytics and Adsense and that sort of
thing, they actually have pixels and presence on a huge percentage
of web pages. You know they have one of the largest
ad networks and so now they know this information and they
can give you ads that are more relevant to you which
is sometimes you know, you can argue that both ways. Oh
you can say that ad's more relevant for me, so that
I am more likely to click on it and it maybe
that is a good thing or it is creepy that this company
knows all of these different websites that I have been to. Generally
we can trust Google, you can't say the same for all ad
networks. So, anyway, that is kind of how they work. They have
got these tracking pixels and when you disable third party cookies in
your browser. You help disconnect yourself a little bit from, from that
sort of tracking. And, you know, I don't mean to pick on
Google specifically, because, you know, they're
actually you know, not too shady.
But there are a lot of shady variations
of this out there. So, that's how it works.